at least 500 explosions recorded in less
than 24 hours along the front lines in
the donbass region of eastern ukraine
and the size of the craters are an
indicator of the heavy weaponry being
used in breach of a limited ceasefire
meant to be in place
russian-backed separatists from a
self-declared republic of luhansk
accused ukrainian forces of starting the
fighting
the situation on a contract line has
been exacerbated dramatically the enemy
is trying to promote active combat
action ukraine's side continues to
violate its obligation to observe the
ceasefire not so say the ukrainian
forces accusing the separatists of being
responsible for all the attacks dozens
of them they say a kindergarten was hit
and this was published on the military
website there were no casualties but the
same picture was being used by russian
media outlets using a different name for
the village that was on their side of
the front line
ukraine says it's a deliberate ploy by
russia it's fake news and
the problem that russian audience are
very susceptible to to this type of of
this information and also the
this
terrorist republics they are trying to
to escalate the level the the this level
because in this situation they feel that
they they could they are one more time
reappear in russian newsletters and in
russian media field
international investigations into who
was responsible for the attacks are
underway
thursday's attacks may have been intense
but no more so than countless other days
in this eight-year-old conflict
it's the timing of what happened and the
disinformation afterwards that has some
western powers thinking
this could be the start of something
much bigger
in brussels the u.s defense secretary
lloyd austin said the situation in
donbass will be watched closely and the
president himself reiterated his warning
that russia may cause an incident as a
forerunner for an invasion
we have reason to believe that they are
engaged in a false flag operation to
have an excuse to go in
every indication we have because they're
prepared to go into the train attack
ukraine
the violence in eastern ukraine has
undoubtedly worsened an already tense
situation here
andrew simmons al jazeera kiev